it's becoming increasingly tricky for
Trumpets to explain away Donald Trump's
hostility towards China and lack of
hostility towards Russia given the
undeniable similarities in some uh
aspect in some in some sense between the
two countries authoritarian questions
real serious questions about human
rights abuses etcetera
there's a fascinating interview
involving Republican congressman Dana
Rohrabacher who has said that he is
being considered for Donald Trump's
Secretary of State he was interviewed by
Yahoo News's bianna golodryga who's from
the former Soviet Union when she brought
up human rights abuses not only did dana
rohrabacher immediately say oh you're
biased he actually started questioning
her country of origin it gets very very
awkward and it's incredibly entertaining
let's take a look at it rights abusers
in China you much can be said about
Russia as well baloney beautify where do
you come from that's right over I came
here as a political refugee okay okay
that's where I came from
what what what country did you say I
come from the former Soviet Union from
oh-ho-ho that's good then you the
audience knows your bias I'm by American
citizen who was born in a foreign
country yeah yeah when you start saying
that Russia should be is it how's that
you you tried you know that there have
been no political reforms in China
none I'm not I'm not advocating to China
be our best friend I'm talking about
Russia jesus said the Russia and China
are the same and I'm sorry they I said
they're both human rights abusers how am
I wrong
how are you wrong in China they don't
have the opposition Russia is an excuse
of murdering journalists uh okay look
you can I let the public decide for that
last comment where you're coming from
the bottom line is what's good for
America is to prioritize as I did when I
worked with Ronald Reagan I wrote most
of his speeches weilman wrong do you
think about your thoughts he wouldn't
know about him if he would maybe you
forgot that Ronald Reagan was the one
who reached out to Gorbachev for this
you comparing Gorbachev to flat Amir
Putin absolutely it is getting very
difficult for these trumpets who
explained why they just
seem to be unwilling to issue serious
critiques of what's going on in Russia
now Dana Rohrabacher first Falls commits
the an ad hominem fallacy by saying
because she is from the Soviet Union she
can't possibly have an unbiased view
about the Soviet Union in the same way
that because Dana Rohrabacher
is not from the Soviet Union he can't
possibly have an unbiased view about the
Soviet Union we've seen this so many
times the right often likes to say LGBT
individuals can't be listened to on
issues related to LGBT rights because
they are inherently biased if you're
straight you're also inherently biased
about LGBT rights because you're not
part of the group so number one this
entire charade is is a complete ad
hominem fallacy the question though was
is or isn't Russia accused of human
rights abuses the answer is yes is or
isn't Russia accused of murdering
journalists that have put information
out there it is incredibly critical and
and potentially damaging to the Kremlin
and the answer is yes and the trumpets
are really going to have to figure out
how to get on message here because it's
becoming very difficult to on the one
hand slam China and on the other hand be
completely tepid in your critique of
Russia when they have so many
similarities in terms of what we're
criticizing them over well I think he
did the right damage control which is
when he gets called out on this he just
pulls out the Ronald Reagan card out of
his back pocket you can always win an
argument with that well but but she was
right though the Ronald Reagan would
have been very distraught by seeing
Republicans now who want to be in the
good graces of Donald Trump not being
critical Vladimir Putin just saying that
Ronald Reagan agrees with you that's
that's the method yeah uh so I who do
you I don't think that this guy came off
well at all
Rachel although if I had to issue a
critique uh of the way the interview was
handled if I were her I would have given
him a little bit more of an opportunity
to finish his sentences before
interrupting him just because I think in
retrospect uh that maybe one way in
which she could be critiqued for how she
handled this she'll definitely be
critiqued for that but I don't nothing
he was saying was very coherent either
no I mean I I and I've done it in
interviews also where if the guest
starts filibustering or distracting or
going in a very
a different direction that what I'm
trying to focus on I will jump in up
very interesting and this really exposes
that there is going to have to be some
messaging that is is coherent here on
Russia and apparently in Rohrabacher z--
world if you mention Russia and human
rights abuses in the same sentence
you're just inherently biased and and
don't deserve to be listened to
everything's by uh backwards all of a
sudden with the election of President
Donald Trump and I think it's only going
to intensify definitely with Russia and
probably with other countries as well we
saw the Taiwan phone call I told you
about on Monday and so much else of
what's going on but very very nice job
there by bianna although I probably
would have interrupted a bit less and
allowed him to I would have given Dana
Rohrabacher a little bit more rope with
which to hang himself
yeah I think she was just very offended
with what he had to say about her and
that what prompted her to keep speaking
I am a big fan of chocolate-covered
strawberries and what's fantastic is
that even vegan david pakman show
producer pat can have dark chocolate
because we established that it does not
have milk in it uh and you can get all
sorts of great combinations at Sherry's
berries berries dot-com BER RIE s.com
dark chocolate milk chocolate white
chocolate chocolate chips the decorative
swizzle chopped nuts more than just
berries as well all sorts of great
seasonal treats in time for the holidays
you can actually once you choose what
you want at berries dot-com BERR IES
dot-com
you can then pre select a delivery date
and it's guaranteed to be delivered on
time when you want and there's only one
way to get the 1999 Sherry's berries
deal and support the david packard show
go to be erri es dot-com click on the
microphone in the top right hand corner
of the website and type in my code
Pakman that's PA que ma n something for
everyone at Sherry's berries go to
Berry's dot-com you click the microphone
and then you type in Pakman this will
give me a gift that people might
actually like and for me that's a pretty
good place to start